words a little bit. What makes what what
necessitates that I am not Libyan? Get
to the question. What necessitates that
I'm not Libbyiano? Sorry, say that one
more time. I'll say it again. I'll say
it slower. You heard me the first three
times. I'll say it slower. If you're
trying to think and stall, I I'll give
you time. Sure thing. What necessitates
that I, Avery Austin, am not Liiano? I
have different accidents.
Are these accidents necessary for you
not to be Avery or for me not to be
Liiano? Yeah, these accidents are
[Music]
all right. So the question
was if Jesus lacks any essential
properties of
Yahweh then he therefore cannot be
Yahweh. Do you agree? Essential
properties uh if you're talking about
related to the essence of course he
can't be Yahweh.
Yeah, essential properties are related
to the essence. That's the distinction
between essential and hypoatic. Well, I
know I I think that you would agree that
you know there are essential hypoatic
properties, right? No, I wouldn't agree.
So that introduces a no arbitrary modal
criteria. What's the grounding for that?
Well, hold on just just a second. So no,
no. Can you can you answer the question?
You said there are
Don't run now. You said you you don't
run. Here you go.
hypat. Look, he's panicking already,
guys. It's
already you said there are essential
hypoatic properties. Yeah. And you said,
would I agree? I say no. Why? Yes. Let
me respond. Essential. Can I finish?
Essentially hypoatic introduces a new
modal uh arbitrary mode
which I don't find any grounding for. Is
there any grounding for this modal mode
that you introduce? If if there is a um
would you would you agree that there's
um No, I need an answer. I am. Would you
agree that there
are I'm answering you and you're cutting
me off. You don't got to show your
nervousness this soon. Like it's too
early. No, we'll see about that. Yeah, I
I guess we will see. Uh would you agree
that there are essential properties to
being persons rather uh than rather than
No, because the very definition Yeah.
The very interesting. You want to let me
finish, man? Yeah. Go ahead. Yeah. The
very the very thing that individuates a
person is his hypothatic properties.
They are not let me finish. They are not
essential. Now you introduced a new
arbitrary mode. Oh, are they essential
to being person? Why are you cutting me
off? You said there are essentially
hyperstatic properties. Yeah, you're not
answering the question, Li. What is
Guys, chat, pay attention to the
question. Yeah. What is the grounding
for the necessity of a hypoatic
property? Yeah, I'll show just like we
were just describing. You just But that
you just said, "Hold on. I'm not repeat
anything." Look at you cutting me off
already. Repeat my question. You being
You being this nervous and showing
already.
Y'all see this chat nervous? I'm about
to demonstrate this to you. Yes. You you
you said that there's not a difference
between h having essential properties to
the essence and having essential
properties to the p to person. I didn't
say that. Yes, you did. That's exactly
what you said. That's exactly what this
guy Yes. That's exactly what you said.
No, this guy today, man. You're caught.
He doesn't even understand what I'm
saying. You're caught today. Okay, I'll
ask again. I'll ask again. Is there a
difference between having essential
properties that make personal versus the
essence? One more time, ladies and
gentlemen. No, answer the question. One
more time. Answer the question. You
introduced the question arbitrary mode.
That is answer the question.
Libya essential. Answer the question
exist. I answer the question. What is
the grounding? Can you answer the
question? Please answer. No, you need to
answer the question. He can't control
himself. He's manifesting. This is you.
You're the one who cut me off. He's
literally manifesting. Answer the
question. Hey brother, are you going to
are you going to stop?
Question. I'm matching your energy with
energy, brother. Hey, Logic. Did you say
did you say there are necessary
hypothatic properties? Excuse me for a
second.
Can you you said that right chat? He
said there are necessary hypothatic
properties. Now this is more like what
is the grounding for the necessity of a
hypothatic property?
So, when you're talking about hypostatic
hypo hypostasis versus essence, there's
a distinction. And because there's a
distinction Oh, I'm cutting me off
already. Look at this.
I bet. Yeah. It's okay. You can nervous.
Laugh all you want. Yo, this guy because
there's a distinction. Because there's a
distinction, Libyano. It's okay. Relax.
Because there's a distinction between
hypoasis and essence. There are
properties that are related to the
essence and there are properties that
are related to personhood or hypoasis.
Hypoatic properties versus properties of
the essence. And so this is why you need
to make the category um uh you highlight
the category you're talking about when
you're talking
about finish. Let me finish. Let me
finish. All right. Finish so I could
respond. I I appreciate it. Thank you,
man. Relax. It's It's okay. We're
beautiful Sunday.
It's all good. I bet. Hey, brother. Come
on. Hurry up so we can get to it. It's
all Hey, the longer you cut me off, the
longer it takes. Hey, brother. Hey,
brother. Come on. Let's get it going.
So, now that we So, now that we've
identified the different categories, how
many of you said earlier? Yeah. You said
earlier that there's no difference
between properties and properties of the
guy right now. How many did you say or
not? Are you going to answer the
question? How many categories? I already
did. Did you answer it? So, can you
answer the question? Are there two or
three? Can you answer the question? Are
there two or three? Can Can you answer
the question? Are there two or three
categories? Yeah, you're not going to
answer the question. Yeah, he's running.
I'm I'm right here. You just ran from
the question. All right. So, remember
Phil is saying every everybody can see
how you're running from the question.
No, he can't control himself. So, is
there a difference between hypoatic
properties and properties of the Can I
speak? Answer the question. Oh, no. Can
I speak? We waited. I speak. Remember I
asked him a question. He didn't answer.
Waiting. Go ahead. Good. Keep waiting.
Remember, we'll see if you answer the
question. He said there are category one
hypothatic properties that individuates
each
hypotheasis. Number two, there are
essential properties that are common and
related to every
hypotheasis. Remember these are the two
categories. In the beginning he
introduced a third arbitrary mode that
is
hyperstatically necessary. So not
hyperatic, not necessary but hypatically
necessary. He introduced a new arbitrary
mode and I'm asking logic and the
question I've been asking him and
because he doesn't understand nothing of
what I'm saying to begin with that's why
he's answering. The question was logic.
What grounds look look at him reading
for the for the discord by the way. What
grounds the necessity of this third
arbitrary mode you introduced.
Okay. So I just listened to you. So
please don't let your panic pop out. So
uh Libiano, you misrepresented me and
it's it's normal for you to do that.
This is what I said. I'll make the
position clear. And you said that you
was going to answer the question and
notice that you didn't. You didn't
answer the question. So here it is. I'll
say it again. I I'll I'll give the
position again. Hopefully this time,
Libbyiano, you can probably engage,
little buddy. Hopefully, you can engage.
Here it is again. There's a difference
between hypoatic properties that are
essential to hypoasis or persons because
these are relational properties. These
will make them distinct from another
from one another. There are also um
properties that are essential to the
essence. Nice. Those are two different
properties categories of properties.
We're talking two categories, right?
Hold on. So, yeah, I don't know where
you got this three this three. Two
categories. No, you're interrupting me
now. Okay. So, when I asked you, do you
agree that there is a difference between
hypoatic properties and properties
essential to the essence? You said no.
You want an answer now? You said no. You
already gave me the answer. I I didn't
say no. Yo, is literally panicking right
now. Let me finish.
Do you want notice? Did I interrupt you?
Do you want an answer? Did I interrupt
you? Do you want an answer? I after I
finish. All right. Go ahead. Thank you.
Yeah. Yeah. It's It's okay. He's doing
everything to get beautiful Sunday
morning. Jesus loves you, Liviano.
You're all good. It's
okay. All right. I know you've been
missing. We're all okay, man. You're
doing okay, man. So, this is where we're
at, Liiano. Keep going. You need to
answer the question. You already said
that there's not a difference between
hypo. I didn't say there's no
difference. Why are you cutting me off?
I didn't say there's no difference. Why
are you cutting me off? This is a
conversation. This is a This is a di you
off though. So you see you see how he's
interact. He can actually engage with
the dialect. But you're not engaging
with the dialogue. Able to engage. Okay.
All right. Let's see. Liiano. Answer the
question then. Is there a difference?
I'll give you a secret. Repeat the
question. Repeat the question. I answer
directly. Then I'm gonna ask you the
question directly. Deal. We'll see. I
already answered your question. We'll
see. I already answer. No, you didn't
answer my question yet. Okay. We'll see.
Answer my question. All right. All
right. So, here here it is again. Here's
your third chance. Redeem yourself.
Question. And then you're going to
answer my question that you've been
ducking. We'll go We'll go ahead. We'll
go ahead. You've been ducking. You've
been ducking this one. We'll see. So,
here it is again. Third chance, Liviana.
Third time's a charm, baby boy. Third
time's a charm. Third time's a charm. Is
there a difference between properties of
the hypoasis that belong to the to the
persons versus properties that are
essential to the essence? Yes or no?
Good. Yeah. So, as I mentioned from the
beginning, there are two categories.
Don't cut me off. There are two
categories. There are essential
properties that are common to each
hypotheasis. I've already mentioned
this. And there are hypothatic
properties that
individuate each hypotheasis. Okay,
there are two distinct categories.
What's the distinction? The distinction
is the essential common property is
necessary to constitute the ontology or
the identity of each hypotheasis. It is
necessary for the thing to have its
quiddity. Okay, that's for the essential
category. For the hypothatic category,
these hypothatic properties individuate
and distinguish between the
individuations between the
hypotheasis. Okay, these are two
categories. But remember hypothatic
properties are not necessary in every
possible world.
He said there is a third group and what
from the beginning when he first joined
he said there are hypatically
essential hypothatically
essential that is a third category in
which you need to substantiate grounding
for the necessity of these accidents can
you please now the question that he's
not gonna answer can you provide
a grounding for why hypothatic
properties are essential or necessary in
every possible world. Okay. Yes. Very
simple. I I said it again. I I'll I'll
say it again. I answered this the first
time. I'll answer it again. Yeah, I'll
answer it again. Because there are
properties that like what you said
individuate a particular hypoasis. So
like for example the uh the the uh the
hypo the hypothesis the hypothesis of
the son right the son is begotten that
is a hypoatic property an essential
hypoatic property of the son the father
begets that is a hypo an essential
hypoatic property of the fathers
essential this is what this is what
makes the essential grounds the
necessity because being the begget you
have you are begetting something. What
grounds that? What do you What do you
mean? What grounds that? The Okay, we'll
try the father. Him. Him him being told
you that. Wait, the camera died. One
second. The camera died. Him being the
person of the father. Don't talk. The
camera died. Wait. What do you mean
don't talk? I'm talking. Why can't we
talk? Don't talk. The camera died. Let
me put in Let me put in batteries. Wait.
Hopefully hopefully you can engage with
what I said. Don't Hey, man. I said
don't speak. I'm my batteries in. We got
to make sure I get the whole
conversation. We got a video that's
going to go viral. conversation. So, so
make sure we get the whole conversation
with my face in it. One second, dude.
The whole conversation is right here,
man. Yeah. Yeah. Good. So, because the
father
begin to continue now. Thank you, man.
I'm going to continue now. Go ahead. You
don't yell this time. Remember he said
the father essentially
beggets the beginning of the father or
the paternity of the father according to
him is hypothatic would I be correct in
saying so Mr. God logic. It's a hypoatic
property. Good. Good. So, the father's
paternity is hypatic, not essential to
the essence. Now, remember he said he
essentially begets. He is
hypothetically. Hypoatically. Yeah. That
that's the point. Yeah. So, make sure
you put that in. Don't don't take it
out. Let me finish. Just don't
misrepresent. Let me finish. Let me
finish. Don't don't manifest. He is he
necessarily hypatically begets. There
you go. I am asking what grounds this
necessity. Why must he as a hypothasis
begget? Why is there no possible world
in which the father lacks paternity?
What grounds this necessity? Because the
father eternally begins. Why? Let me let
me let me answer that. Why? Why? Why?
What? What grounds God being all
knowing? What grounds what grounds God
being all powerful? Like let me finish.
Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me
finish. Let me finish. Notice how he's
notice how
he's bro. Can you
talk? This is This is insane. This is
insane. This is tough.
So the father being the father he
begets. That means that because the
father begets. Oh, love is relational.
What grounds that? Love and relation.
It's love and relation. He begets.
Because Liiano, you going to let me
talk? You're not answering. I I
literally am. You're cutting me off at
every turn, bro. And And then you
complain if I if I cut in you. You
complain that I cut you off. Let me
finish. I'm asking Liiano. I'm asking
you to let me finish, bro. Just like you
did me. Yeah, finish. I let you finish.
Finish. Let me finish. Let me talk.
Thank you. So, because of the because
the father begets and this is necess
this is necessary. He's always the
father eternally unchanging. He's always
the father. I'm telling you. Are you not
listening to the answer? Yeah. No. No.
You're saying are you not listening to
the answer? I'm saying again. It's a
hypoatic necessity. Look.
You got to let me answer, bro. I'm I'm
going to help you out here because
you're You have to let me answer. You
have to let me answer. Okay. All right.
I'm going to give you let's say one
minute. Don't time me. You just got to
let me talk. That's all. One minute. Go
ahead. You just got to let me talk.
Finish everything you have to say in the
one minute. Go ahead. I appreciate it.
Thank you so much. Yes, please. So
because the father is eternally the
father, he eternally begets which makes
him eternally the father and which and
this beginning is a hypothetic re
relation with the father and the son.
The begotten and the beet and the same
with the spirit. The spirit spirates
from the father. So these are eternal
these are eternal actions. These are
it's an eternal procession an eternal
beginningness. These are hyposstatic
necessities. They always happen. They do
not happen in time. That's why it's
necessary. That's it's infinite. It
doesn't happen in time. So with that
being said, Liiano, you agreed that
there is a difference between properties
that belong to hypoasis and properties
that belong to the essence. So I gave
you your answer. So now can you deal
with my question? Is it okay if you if
you deal with my question? You haven't
answered yet. And I already answered
you. Oh, he said I haven't answered. The
one minute The one minute is sticking.
He said I haven't answered yet. Yeah,
I'm I'm ready to get to demonstrate how
Jesus is the most high. Oh, yeah. He's
running. He's running, ladies and
gentlemen. Man, question. I'm just gonna
have to keep repeating myself for you. I
gave you repeating myself.
Uninterrupted. Stop it. I'm have to keep
repeating myself for you. You're too
slow to get this. Yeah. Stop. Stop
bickering, dude. You're embarrassing.
Yeah. Listen, I'm embarrassing you. This
is Are we gonna get to Are we gonna get
to We're already here. We've been here
for the last You're married right now.
It's actually 15 20 minutes. I bet. I
can't wait till this goes up. All All of
that helps you out. I bet. I'm gonna
speak, bro. I'm gonna speak. Thank you,
man. So, guys,
remember two categories, hypothetic,
essential. Let's use a human being for
example. Essential to the essence. A
human. Yeah. To the essence, right?
That's what essential means essential to
the to the hypers and there's essential
property. All right, let's take a human
being for example. A human being
essentially has a soul that's an
essential
property related to humanity as an usa
as a common essence amongst all the
hypotheases of individual humans. me I'm
an
individuation of the essence humanity.
Okay. My hypothatic property for example
is being
Libyan. Now could I say because I am
Libyan in this world and because I am
Libyano I am necessarily in every
possible world Libyan. No, because God
could have actualized me as a non
Libyan. So, and not necessarily
hypothically anything because the very
definition of a hypothatic property is a
property that could be
otherwise. It's a property that could be
otherwise. It's not a necessary
condition for being me. He said
introduced a third category. He's saying
because the father is the father in
every possible world it is necessary for
him to be get. I'm saying just like in
every possible world I'm not Libyan. And
if I made that case let's say I said in
every possible world I'm a Libyan. It's
necessary for me to be that way. Someone
could ask me what grounds that
necessity. Why is it that in every
possible world you are a Libyan? There's
no grounding for that necessity because
there's a possible world where I'm not
Libyan. He's introducing a third
category. He's saying there is
hyperstatic
essential. So there's essential one,
hypothetic two, and third category is
hypothetically essential. It's
gibberish. It doesn't exist. So Mr.
Logic, I'm going to bury you in front of
your fans now. Answer the damn question.
What grounds the necessity of the
paternity of the father being a
hypothatic property?
Does a father beget Libyaniano in this
world? Yeah. Okay. Um if you are if you
are the father who begets, what do you
beget?
A son in this world. Okay. So to be the
father, it necessitates beginning.
Correct. In this world. Yeah. Okay.
So when this is why must why must he be
a father in every world? Let me finish.
Let me finish and show you what just
happened here. Yes. What you just
acknowledged is that it is a essential
property of a father to be a
father. Can you be a father? Can you be
a father without begetting? If you're in
this world where you're hypothetically a
father, then you have to have a son. So
you cannot you're not a father. Do you
want an answer? He's panicking. If you
are not a father in every possible
world, then you are saying that the
father could be not a father in a
possible world.
In every possible world is a father. In
what world does a father begin? A
grounding for the necessity. In what
world does a father not be? What do you
mean? In a world where he doesn't have
paternity. Oh, so then you're not a
father then, right? Right. So why
father? So there you Oh my goodness. So
you just notice what you just did. You
you don't even know what you just did.
You're you're done. Just dust. You're
dust. Watch this. You notice what you
just did. So you just acknowledged that
beginning is a necessary property of
being the father. Slow. Oh my goodness.
So you just acknowledge that there are
necessary or quote unquote essential
hyposatic properties. Numb nuts. So
because God is the father, him be
getting is a necessary property. Does he
have to be a father? An essential
property. Does he have to be a father?
Let me finish. Does he have to be a
father? Let me finish. Does he have to
be a father? Let me finish. All right.
Finish. He's in him beginning is an
essential necessary property of the
hypostasis.
Because let me Okay. I I know. I I know.
I I've seen this before. I've I've seen
it with Hamza. I've seen it with Ramsey.
I let you speak uninterrupted. I let you
speak uninterrupted.
You just got caught. It's okay. You just
got caught. It's all good. Okay. Your
rhetoric doesn't work here, bro. Well,
it's working right here because look, I
bet you nervous happened. You my son
right now. You're my I know. I miss you.
I have you on.
I heard you've been calling me so I
came. to go get my milk. I left to go
get my milk from the grocery store. I
came back when you thought I wasn't
going to come back from the grocery
store, but I came back, son. I came
back. You have to be a father. I came
back. I came back. So, you have to be a
father. So, now to continue to be a
father. He's a father. Yes. Necessarily
a father. That's what Are you listening?
Yeah. I'm trying. You're not answering.
Maybe turn up turn up the headphones.
Turn up the head. Yeah. It's up. Does he
have to be a father? Turn up the
headphones. Stop cutting me off. Have to
be a father. Stop cutting me off now.
Oh, chat.
You guys know what's happening in
chat? Y'all see what's happening in chat
today. Is this just a father in every
possible so nervous he has to interrupt.
He has to panic and the nervous lab
doesn't work here. Does he have to be a
father? Yes. People getting frustrated.
Relax. He literally can't answer. Dude,
he literally cannot answer me. Well, I'm
trying to. I'm just getting interrupted.
So, the question is, does he have to be
Wait, hold on. Hold on. I'm I'm already
answering something. Relax. So, thank
you. So, let me talk. Let me talk.
Appreciate it. Focus. So you just you
just you just demonstrated you just
demonstrated that it is a necessary
hypoatic property. It's an essential
hypoatic property for the father to be
the father to beget. Begetting is a
necessary property of hypoasis of
fatherhood of paternity. So, you just
acknowledged that there are essential
properties of
hypostasis, which in the beginning you
said there wasn't. Are you done? You
said this is a third category that he
just made up. Are you done? But you just
acknowledged that. Are you done? Let me
finish. Are you done? Let me finish.
Waiting waiting for the answer, man.
You're just You're just cutting me off.
You're cutting me off, bro. You keep
saying that I didn't answer doesn't mean
that I didn't answer. I'm I'm gonna give
you I'm gonna give you another minute.
It's all good. It's all good. It's all
good. I want you to interact with what I
with what we're saying here. You're
incapable of engaging with what's being
said, Libyaniano. You can't engage with
what's being said. Only thing you can do
is talk over. You can try to change the
question. Change the question. Change
the question. It's not happening, bro.
So, you need to engage with what's being
said. engage with the fact that you just
acknowledged that there are hypo
essential hypoatic properties and you
just acknowledged that beginning is an
essential hypoatic property of being the
father. That's what you need to so can
you acknowledge that? I just want to
hear you acknowledge that.
You have 20 seconds. I just want you to
acknowledge
that it's 18 seconds. Let me know when
you're done. I just want you to
acknowledge that. I'm I'm just wait I'm
waiting for you question. Yeah, I'm
waiting for you to answer a question.
All right, good. All right, good. So,
he's done now. He's not going to cut me
off. Let's see if he answers the
question, y'all. Let's see if he
question. Look, he's lit. He's literally
Let's see if he answers the question.
Who told you to come here, bro? Bad
idea, brother. Bad idea. Yeah, it's a
bad idea for you. You You ever since
you've been You've been calling for me,
man. Calling me out. You've been missing
me. Can I talk? You I I left to go get
milk. You thought I wasn't gonna come
back.
It's all good. I'm I'm back now, man.
All right. Here we go. So, he's saying
he's saying
when one is a
father, okay, when one is a father,
okay, he must be. That's the meaning of
what a father is. But the question
was why must the first person be a
father and what grounds this necessity?
Because you are saying although it is
hypothetic it is necessary across every
possible world and I am positing that
this is an arbitrary uh uh uh mode that
you're using. Why? Okay. I'll tell you
why. I'll tell you why. That's a very
good question you asked. Thank you.
something is either necessary, essential
and related to the to the liquidity of a
thing, to the essence of a thing or not
necessary and related to the
individuation of a thing. Okay? So for
example, I'm a human. Me having a soul
relates to my humanity. We don't know
what happens. Let me finish. I could not
be a human without having a soul because
having a soul is essential. Not to my
hypothasis. It's not essential because
I'm Liby. It's essential because I'm a
human related to my usa. Okay. As you
say now, me being
Libyan, one could be a human and not be
Libyan. So being Libyan is hypothatic.
What's necessary? What's necessary for
being Libyan? What are you talking
about? What is necessary to be Libyan?
Man, let me finish. No, no, look at you.
Look, you you understood the question.
What's necessary for you to be living?
Let me finish. Look at
[Laughter]
you
like trying everything right now. He is
literally
trying. You are done. Let me finish. Let
me finish. Answer the question. What's
necessary for you to be? What's
necessary for being Libyan is born in
Libya? What? All right. Sounds good.
What is necessary to being Liby? person.
What's necessary? Finish. Let me finish.
Let's do this. Let me finish. What's
wrong with you? He's literally He's He's
lost it right now, bro. No. No. You lost
it. Look, I look I said off my
train question, dude. Let me finish.
Okay. What is necessary for being with
me? You have to let me finish. Yes, you
are. Listen, now he's uninterrupted. Now
he's gonna mute me. You spoke for a
minute uninterrupted. You spoke
uninterrupted, too. Don't be a coward.
Don't be a coward. You just you don't be
a coward and answer the question.
Integrity. Let me finish. You're a
coward, man. I am. What makes it
necessary? Literally can't control
himself. Let me finish. All right.
It's not necessary to humanity. One
could be a human and be Libyan. Could be
Canadian, American, Algerian, Chinese,
all be human. Why? Because it is an
individuating property. and it's a
hypoatic one. Could I then come and say,
well, Mr. Logic, me being Libyan is
actually a essentially hypothatic
property, meaning that across every
possible world, I am essentially
necessarily hypothically Libyan. But
what grounds that necessity? Why must I
be Libyan across every possible world?
The essence doesn't ground it because
you could be a human and not be Libyan.
So what grounds this necessity sir? Can
you tell me why must the father have
paternity in across all possible worlds?
No, you need no lio. You ran from the
question. Liiano, you ran from the
question. Notice how you keep switching
from you keep switching from hypothetic
necessary properties and essential
properties essential. There's no such
thing. Okay. So Liviano, if there's no
such thing as hypothetically necessary,
that's the point. Okay. Okay. Can you be
Liiano and not be human? Okay. Can you
be Libbyiano and not be human? Libbyo
and not be human. Can I be No, Libbyiano
is a human necessarily.
So, so is every human libiano? No. Oh,
so being Li being Libyano is not
necessary to be human. Liiano is a human
because Libby possesses human making
propert. I didn't ask that. That's not
listen to the question. Hold on. Re
restart. Listen to the question. I
didn't ask. I didn't ask about Libya
being human. I asked what makes this
human being Oh, excuse me. What makes
this human being that I'm talking to
necess Libyan? What makes you Libbyiano?
My human making properties and not my
hypothic ones. Okay. So, is every human
making does every human making property
equal libiano? No. Because Okay. So, you
can so you could be a human basis of the
of the I got you. So, you could be a
human without being Libbyiano. Correct.
That's the point. Thank you.
Okay. Being a
father. Hold on though. Hold on. What
you just saw without having paternity
and without having a father. Oh my god.
You don't even know what you just did.
You just You just proved my point. You
just proved my point. Oh my goodness.
You just proved my point. You just
proved my point, Liano. Because what
we're saying is is that you just like
you what you just said. You don't have
to be a father. You don't have to be the
father to be essentially God. Which is
why the son is not the father. The holy
spirit is let me finish. Hold on. No.
You just prove my point. You don't even
know. But you just proved my point. Let
me finish. You just buried yourself. Let
me finish now. So just like what you
just said. Just like what you just said,
Leiano. You don't have to be the father
in order to be essentially God. So being
the father that hypoasis is not
essential to the essence. It's a
hypoatic property about paternity.
Hypoatic relation. Let me finish. Let me
finish. I'm asking about paternity. Let
me finish. You just you just caught and
buried yourself. So just like what you
just did. Hold on. Hold on. What you
just did was you said you do not have to
be the father in order to essentially be
God. Welcome to Christianity. We say God
is triune and the son is essentially God
while being distinct from the father.
The spirit is essentially God while
being distinct from the father. Just
like you are Libyano, but you don't have
to be uh you don't have to essentially
be um or or you you could be human
without essentially being Libyano. So,
you just proved the point that there's
other Let me finish. Let me finish.
Let's deal with that. Oh my goodness.
It's okay. It's okay. I'm I'm about to
wrap up. So, just like what you said,
you don't have to be the father to be
God. So there are essential hypoatic
properties that make the father the
father. It it it individuates him from
the son or the spirit. These are
essential properties that make the
distinction. Okay. However, these
hypothatic essential properties, these
essential properties of the
hypostasis are not the same when it
comes to the essence. So there are
essential properties of the essence that
are not essential properties of the
hypostasis or the persons. You done? All
right. There you go. You got your
answer. You're done. There we go. Thank
you for He's running. He's running. Good
job. Good job. He's running now. Are you
ready to go to the scripture now? Let's
use Let's use everybody. Everybody, I
want you to pay close. Notice how he's
running from the scripture. Can I Can
I scripture? Can I speak? Can I speak?
You're running from the scripture. I
want everybody to watch the New
Testament that Jesus is God. We haven't
even got there yet. What's up with this
guy? You just deal with your title, man.
To do with your title, everybody. This
is too easy. Everybody get your cameras
on. This is too easy. The camera's
already on, man. You got caught in 4K.
Let's look. Look. He's He's He's so
scared right now. He's You got caught in
4K, bro. It's over. I know. I know. I'm
I I know I'm your father, dude. Just
relax. Just move on. This this doesn't
help. I wasn't helping. Look at this
guy. Let me let me let me let me make my
point. I want all the cameras start
clipping. Let's use your analogy logic.
You said Liiano doesn't have to be
Liiano to be human. Is that correct,
Logic? No, that's not what I said. Yo.
Yo, that's not what he said.
Yo, he's backtracking. He's backing. I
said Liiano doesn't have to be Liiano to
be human.
Yo yo this guy is backtracking, bro. I
need clip. Clip, man. Clip. Clip. What
did I say? Orthodox. You said because
Liiano doesn't have to be Liiano to be
human. That means the son doesn't have
to be the father to be God. You know
what? Yeah, I misheard you. I I mis I
misunderstood what you said. I thought
you misunderstood the enemy. My bad. But
yeah. Yeah. Mard. All right. So, let's
try again. Liiano does not have to be
Liiano to be God. Correct. To be God. Or
to be human, right?
Yeah. Good. Good. Because Libyano being
Libyan is hypothatic. Correct. Yeah.
It's a personal The father being a
father is also hypothic.
Yes. It's a hypothetic property. So the
father doesn't have to be the father to
be God, right? No. God. God. So could be
did you listen to the
answer? This is stupid. Uh being being
the father being the father is not
essential to the essence. That's a
hypoatic property. So just like being
essential to humanity that's why it
could otherwise in another possible
world just just like we have so the son
the son is not the father yet he's
essentially god again. Again let's try
this again. Yeah let's try this again.
If Liiano being Libyan is
hypothatic, therefore
does not have to be Libyan to be human.
Let's change our variables. The father
is hypothatically the father. Therefore,
he does not have to be the father to be
God, right? No, you're mixing this up,
Liviano. Listen, listen to the listen to
the breakdown here, dude. Nice try. But
listen to the breakdown. You notice
notice how you switched and you and you
tried to do it uh you know it was kind
of cute. You you you tried to switch it
up when we're talking about Libyano
there. You can be you you don't have to
be Libyano to be human. Just like when
it comes to the persons of the trinity
you don't have to be the father. There's
you can you cannot be the father or be
distinct. You can be distinct from the
father and still
you can be distinct from the father and
not and still go. You can still be you
can still be God and not the father.
Yes. You can still be God and not the
father. Liano. Now what you have to do
is what you have to do is hold on.
We already did that.
Liviano, can you can you can you just
hold on a second? Liviano, can you just
hold on a second? Yeah. So, notice how
what you're doing, you're trying to uh
uh switch interchangeably. Yeah. Okay.
Uh personhood and the nature, the
essence and the hypoasis. And it's not
going to work here, dude. Stop. It's not
going to work here. It's not going to
work here. So when we're talking about
the persons and what makes God
essentially or what makes the persons
essentially God, the son is distinct
from the father yet he's essentially
God. So he doesn't have to be the person
of the father to be essentially God.
There's no problem with that in the
trinity. There is. You want to know why?
What's the problem? Because I asked you,
is paternity essential or hypothetic?
You said it's hypoatic not essential.
No. Stop. Stop. Stop. I said that that
paternity is hyposatically essential to
the father because it's a relationship
because good because now you introduce
the third category. It's not a third
category. There's hypothatic
accidents. There is necessary essential
related to the essence and that's it.
You introduce the third one
hypothetically
essential. Now, because you introduce a
third arbitrary mode, the question is
because you admit that paternity is
hypothetic, but you're saying it's
hypothetically essential, meaning it's
hypothetic, meaning that not all the
hypotheses share it, but it's also
necessary in every possible world. And
my question is, no, stay here. What
grounds this Yeah, I'm here. What
grounds this necessity? Why is it that
the father begets in every possible
world? Because of love and his relation
with the son. He's eternal. It's it's an
eternal beginning. It doesn't it's not
it doesn't it's eternal. It's infinite.
It doesn't happen in in time. This is
why it's it's just the world.
Liiano, watch this. You you would agree
that there are necessary properties that
make you Liiano and not me Libyano.
Correct? No, they're hyposic. Not
necessary. Okay. What what
what necess what necessitates that I'm
not living? You're doing okay. We'll
see. We'll see. Cuz I because I'm I'm
just flabbergasted by by this. I know
you're messing on your words a little
bit. What What necessitates that I am
not Libyan? Get to the question. What
necessitates that I'm not Libbyiano?
Sorry. Say that one more time. I'll say
it again. I'll say it slower. You heard
me the first three times. I'll say it
slower. You're trying to think and
stall. I I'll give you time. Sure thing.
What necessitates that I, Avery Austin,
am not Libyano? I have different
accidents.
Are these accidents necessary for you
not to be Avery or for me not to be
Libyano? Yeah, these accidents are going
to I haven't even answered. I haven't
even answered. You said yes. You said
yeah.
You said guys been trying so hard. I
haven't even answered. Well, you didn't
just say yeah. I haven't even answered,
dude. You just said
you just said yes. He's trying so hard.
I'll give you another chance. I'll give
you another chance. Are these necessary
for you to be with and not Avery? I'm
going to answer you. I'm going to answer
you. Go ahead. What distinguishes you
between uh what distinguishes you and me
is are our accidents. If we didn't have
any accidents, we would be one in the
same subject. Therefore, it is necessary
for us to have accidents in order for us
to be different hypothesis. Are these
accidents Are these accidents necessary
to your hypoasis? Not individually. No.
Okay. So, I'll ask it again then. I I
just said no. No, I know you just said
no. They could be otherwise. Okay. So,
this mean this means that it takes us
back then. What necessitates that you
are answer? No. Deal with it.
What? Liviano, this isn't working. I've
been asking every question. No, you have
not. You You've been flipfpping on your
stuff. You've been flip popping on your
stuff, bro. What
necessitates? Give me specifics. What
necessitates that
you're distinguish between us? The
question, bro. What are those? Avery,
you keep ducking. I'm not going to let
you duck anymore. Yo, what are those?
The question was answer the question.
What grounds the necessity? Stop
running.
You already answered that. Father having
paternity. Can you answer what? I I
already answer. Good. I I already
answered that. I already answered that.
The problem here, Liiano, is that
whenever you get caught, you're trying
to divert as if this was an answer in
dealt with. Oh my god. So again, Liby
when you say Lato when you say that
there are necessary accidents that make
me different from you. Let me finish.
When you say that there are accidents
that make that that necessarily make me
distinct from you, you are acknowledging
that there are necessary hypothetic
properties that distinguish us. But then
you say that there's not. So then I'm
asking you, Liviano, I'm asking you. I'm
asking you all of this question. What
are the properties that makes Libiano
the person Liiano, not the person Avery?
I'm going to answer for the third
time. In a world where Avery and I are
distinct
hypostasis, it follows that because we
are distinct. What makes us distinct?
Let me finish. Not answer the question.
Let me finish. I'm answering. You're not
answering the question, though. It
follows in a world where Avery and
Libyano are distinct hypo stasis. It
follows because a distinction all it is
is an asymmetry in properties. Okay. If
in a possible world we have an asymmetry
in properties it follows then we have
distinct accidents. However these
distinct what's the distinction? Let me
finish. However, for example, waiting
for you to answer the question. Let me
finish, dude. Let me finish. Just answer
the question in any time. For example, I
have a nice beard. Avery has whatever
that is that's that's on his face. Okay,
these things are
accidents. Okay, they are accidents
waiting on you. Distinguish us. He has
whatever that is on his face and I have
a nice luscious beard. Okay.
But in a possible world, what does that
have to do with being could be the case
that I don't have this nice, juicy,
luscious beard? It could be otherwise.
Does that make you question answered?
You see guys, no, it's not answered.
It's not answered. Does that make Does
that make you Liiano? Does your beard
make you? My question. No. Does your
beard make? Nice try. This is pathetic.
This is pathetic. Does your beard make
you? No, bro. If you don't answer the
question, you need to answer. Go. You
can run all you want. You can run all
you want. Go ahead and run away.
So, your beard makes you the question.
All right. Does your beard make you stop
manifesting? Stop. No, you're
manifesting. You can't answer the
question. It's okay. It's going to be
fine. Deal with it. I know. I know. Does
your beard make you the second time
after this finishes? Does your beard
make you Libyan?
Breathe. Take it in. can't do it. You
can't do it inside, brother. It's
humili. I get it. Answer the question. I
just said I just did. So now I'm
So your beard makes you that have been
posing since
a beard is a is a nec necessity.
Go run away. Hold on. Let's go. Go ahead
and run away. You need to you need to be
muted. Go ahead. Go ahead and run away.
You're not answering question. Where to
kick me? Are you going to answer the
question or no? Anyway, are you all
right? So, are you going to be quiet
because you're you keep interrupting me?
So, are you saying having a beard is is
your hypoatic property? Is having a
beard? Yes, having a beard is
accidental. Yes. Oh. So, so is No,
that's not what I asked you. Is having a
beardic property is an accident. Okay.
So, so when you say that then can you
have your beard and not be libiano? I
could have I could be Liiano without
having my beard. Oh, so having a beard
or not having a beard does not make you
make you or not make you Libbyiano,
right? Because it is not necessary in
every possible world. What makes you
lio? So now logic. So now logic
presented to us. You're still not
answering the question. Hypothetic
properties are not
necessarily the world. I can't believe
you ground the necessity for paternity.
You're not answering the question.
You're not answering the question. My
question doesn't make you say anymore.
Yeah, I know. You don't say anymore. At
first you said first you said having a
beard makes for who Liviano is. That
makes a distinction between us and now
you're saying it doesn't. Are you What
makes you logic? Logic. Are you gonna
answer the question? Come on. Come on.
What makes you Liiano? He is literally
panicking right now. I bet this doesn't
help you. If you want if you want to
kick me and run away from the question,
that's all good. That's all good, man.
No, man. This video is going to blow up.
Oh, you Oh, you're right. You're right.
It's going to blow up, man. Hey, make
sure you don't misrepresent. I want you
to post this on your channel. Catch when
you run. Make sure you catch when you
run. Are you going to post Make sure you
catch when you run. Are you going to
post it? Oh. Oh. All of this is going to
be there. All of this post on your
channel. You think you say that your
brother is going to be on the channel,
guys? To his word.
Post this. You better not delete this,
too. Oh, by the way, are you gonna
copyright me? Are you going to copyright
me? Logic, are you going to post this on
the main channel? Are you gonna Are you
going to copyright me? Of course not.
Okay, cool. Yeah, we're good. Be
everywhere. Copyright you, dude. Just
making sure. Just making sure. You're
gonna post this on your main channel,
right? It's gonna be everywhere. It's
gonna be everywhere. All right, good.
Good. And I'm gonna post this on my main
channel and on my channel so people can
see that you are a fraud. So now and
people can see that you're a
liar. You can't even
Hey sir, what are we doing here, man?
Are you not? You didn't answer the
question. I answered every question you
gave. Answer
you. You still did not tell me what
makes you I know you are. You're getting
tired of getting stirred.
Are you Are you going to answer the
question? I'm getting tired to get
stirred up. Yeah. Are you going to
answer the question? Still have not
answered the question of what makes you
All right. All right. I'm going to try
one more time. Yeah, we can try one more
time. We can try one more time. Grounds.
The necessity of paternity across all
worlds. Okay. And and then I'll respond
to this, please. What makes you Libya?
[Laughter]
See, you can't answer the question.
Thank Thank you for coming, man.
Appreciate you. Keep running.
Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]